♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE MOB IS MELTING
DOWN TONIGHT AFTER VIRGINIA
GOVERNOR GLENN YOUNGKIN ON THE
STATE'S NEW LEADERSHIP THEY ARE
ACTUALLY FOLLOWING THROUGH ON
THEIR CAMPAIGN PROMISES LIKE
UNDATED DRACONIAN MASK MANDATES
AND TO STANDING UP TO
INDOCTRINATION IN SCHOOLS,
ACTUALLY GIVING PARENTS A SAY IN
THEIR KIDS EDUCATION.
AND STANDING UP AGAINST
ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL MEDICINE WITH
THE FAILED FAKE NEWS FRAUD JIMMY
ACOSTA, FAKE NEWS A COST.
SIMILAR TO THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION.
>> IN OFFICE IN LESS THAN TWO
WEEKS AS GOVERNOR, GLENN
YOUNGKIN HAS ALREADY SET UP AN
EMAIL TO BLIND FOR PARENTS TO
REPORT TO TEACHERS FOR TEACHING
"DIVISIVE SUBJECTS."
>> I SEEM TO REMEMBER HIM IN A
FLEECE VEST IN VIRGINIA HE WAS
RUNNING AS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
REPUBLICAN.
I WAS TOLD THERE WAS GOING TO BE
A VEST.
>> THAT'S FOR GOOD NEWS.
SOVIET STYLE POLICE STATE.
GIVING STUDENTS AND PARENTS
FREEDOM WHETHER TO MASK IS
ACTUALLY THE OPPOSITE OF A
SOVIET POLICE STATE AND BRACING
FREEDOM OF THOUGHT, STANDING UP
TO LEFT WING PROPAGANDA,
INDOCTRINATION IS LITERALLY THE
OPPOSITE OF A SOVIET POLICE
STATE.
IMAGINE LIVING AND A FAR LEFT
BUBBLE THAT YOU ACTUALLY THINK
INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM IS SOMETHING
THAT IS EVIL.
OF COURSE, IT DIDN'T STOP THERE
IS EXTREME FAR LEFT SINGER JOHN
LEGEND IS NOW CALLING ON HIS
FOLLOWERS TO FLOOD A NEW
VIRGINIA TIP ALIGNMENT FOR
PARENTS TO BLOW THE WHISTLE ON
CRTV TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS.
LEADERSHIP IN VIRGINIA, IF
STANDING STRONG, DOING WHAT THEY
SAID THEY WOULD DO.
HERE AT THE REACTION, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JASON VR US IS
BACK WITH US.
I REMEMBER A MOMENT IN THE
CAMPAIGN AGAINST
TERRY McAULIFFE WHERE GLENN
YOUNGKIN ACTUALLY SAID NO,
PARENTS SHOULD HAVE A SAY IN
THEIR KIDS EDUCATION.
I REMEMBER THE BIGGEST PLUNDER
OF THE CAMPAIGN WITH
TERRY McAULIFFE SAYING THAT
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE A SAY IN
THEIR KIDS EDUCATION.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, AND MY
RIGHT ON THAT RECOLLECTION?
>> THANKS, SEAN.
YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT THE ENTIRE CAMPAIGN IS
SAYING PARENTS MATTER AND VOTERS
RESPOND TO THAT.
I THINK WHAT JIM ACOSTA SAID --
LISTEN, MY FAMILY FLED TO.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
SOVIET STYLE LOOKS LIKE, IT'S
THE OPPOSITE OF FREEDOM.
MY MOTHER HAS THIS BEEN A GOOD
MEMORY OF BEING FORCED TO TAKE
CLASSES IN MARXISTS -- SAYING
HER BROTHER IS GETTING ARRESTED
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT BY
SECRET POLICE WITH NO DUE
PROCESS, NO SENSE A BILL OF
RIGHTS, AND SEEING THEIR FAMILY
HOME NATIONALIZED ALL IN THE
NAME OF FAIRNESS AND EQUITY.
CLEARLY HE MAY BE NEEDS TO TAKE
SOME HISTORY CLASSES OF WHAT
SOVIET STYLE COMMUNISM ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE.
THAT IS THE OPPOSITE.
WHAT WE HAVE SAID HIS PARENTS
MATTER.
IF YOU ARE A PARENT, SHAWN, AND
YOU WANT TO MASK YOUR CHILD FOR
SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT HOURS A DAY,
YOU ABSOLUTELY HAVE THAT RIGHT.
THAT IS THEIR INDIVIDUAL
DECISION.
BUT IF YOU ARE ALSO WITH A CHILD
OF THAT HAS ASTHMA OR GLASSES,
YOU ALSO HAVE THAT RIGHT PAIR
THAT IS WHAT A PLURALISTIC
SOCIETY LOOKS LIKE.
RECOGNIZE OTHER PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO COME TO DIFFERENT
CONCLUSIONS.
AND BY THE WAY, WHEN YOU
REFERENCE THE OUTCOME OF THAT
CODE OF VIRGINIA SAID PARENTS
HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO THE
UPBRINGING AND WILL BRING UP
THEIR PEOPLE IN THE GREAT IRONY
OF ALL THIS IS NOT SOVIET STYLE
COMMUNIST STATES LIKE CUBA, THE
STATE DOES DIMINISH HIS PARENTS.
THEY SAID THEIR LOYALTY IS TO
THE STATE AND PARENTS HAVE LESS
CONTROL.
THIS IS ABOUT PARENTAL
EMPOWERMENT.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU JUST
SAID.
THIS IS WHAT FREEDOM LOOKS LIKE.
LET PARENTS MAKE THESE
DECISIONS.
NOT A ONE-SIZE-FITS-ALL FOR
EVERYBODY AND EVERY SCHOOL
PRAYER THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
ARE DOING.
I CAN SEE IS FAR LEFT SCHOOL
BOARDS THAT ARE IGNORING THE
VOICES OF THE PARENTS.
>> Sean: THE GOVERNOR MADE A
PROMISE HE WOULD AND CRITICAL
RACE THEORY BEING TAUGHT IN
SCHOOL.
MAYBE I'M OLD-FASHIONED.
I WENT TO 12 YEARS OF CATHOLIC
SCHOOLS AND I HAD A UNIFORM.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE YEARS.
I DON'T KNOW, WE PAY MORE PER
CAPITA PER STUDENT THAN ANY
OTHER COUNTRY IN THE
INDUSTRIALIZED WORLD TO EDUCATE
OUR KIDS.
WE COME IN ANYWHERE BETWEEN 37
AND 40 SECONDS WORLDWIDE.
WE ARE NOT GETTING ANY BANG FOR
OUR BUCK.
MAYBE BEING OLD-FASHIONED I
WOULD THINK READING, WRITING,
MATH, SCIENCE, COMPUTERS.
MAYBE THAT OUGHT TO BE THE FIRST
PRIORITY OF EDUCATING OUR KIDS
AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STANDARDIZED TESTING GOES UP AND
THAT EVERY KID IS PROFICIENT IN
ALL OF THOSE SUBJECTS.
WOULDN'T THAT BE A BETTER PLAN?
>> A MUCH BETTER PLAN.
WHAT WE HEARD THROUGHOUT THE
CAMPAIGN IS THAT THEY WERE
CONCERNED.
NOBODY WE MET SAID, DO NOT TEACH
THE DARK CHAPTERS OF AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THEY SAID TO TEACH ALL OF
AND WE ARE INDEED THAT LOST HOPE
ON EARTH.
IT'S THE SAME HOPE THAT GAVE A
SECOND CHANCE TO MY FAMILY AND
I'VE SAID BEFORE, AMERICA HAS
GIVEN MORE SECOND CHANCES TO
MORE PEOPLE FOR MORE
BACKGROUNDS, MORE FACE, MORE
CREED THAN ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN
THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
THAT ALSO IS WHAT WE SHOULD BE
TEACHING OUR KIDS THAT WEAR THAT
LAST HOPE ON EARTH FOR THERE'S
NO OTHER COUNTRY LIKE US.
AND IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME,
SEAN.
GO TO YOUR LOCAL COURTHOUSE AND
WATCHED A NATURALIZATION
CEREMONY.
THE PEOPLE IN THOSE ROOMS
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS A UNIQUE
SPECIAL PLACE.
THEY CHERISH FREEDOM.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE SHOULD
BE TEACHING OUR KIDS.
YOU'RE RIGHT, OUR NUMBERS RIGHT
NOW WITH THE SHUTDOWN OF OUR
SCHOOLS, OUR MATH SCORES,
READING SCORES, IT HAS BEEN
DEVASTATING FOR SO MANY.
GET HER KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL.
WE LET PARENTS DECIDE WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE MASKS.
WE WANT TO TEACH THEM WHAT TO
THINK, NOT HOW TO THINK.
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WITH VIRGINIA.
>> EXPLAIN THE TIP LINE REALLY
QUICKLY.
IF PARENTS HAVE A PROBLEM IN
THEIR SCHOOL SYSTEM, WHO WILL GO
THROUGH THAT TIP LINE AND LOOK
INTO MATTERS THAT MIGHT BE
SERIOUS?
>> ALL THIS IS SAYING THAT
PARENTS HAVE A RIGHT IF THEY
FIND OUT SOMETHING IS REALLY
CONSIGNING THEM AND WE ARE SEEN
SCHOOL BOARD AFTER SCHOOL BOARD
AND ALL OVER THAT CANDIDLY ARE
JUST IGNORING PARENTS VOICES,
NOT ALLOWING THEM TO SPEAK.
IN SOME CASES PARENTS ARE
GETTING ARRESTED FOR SAYING
LISTEN, WE BELIEVE IN
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
IN GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS ALL WE BELIEVE IN.
THE IDEAS ALLOWING PARENTS TO
HAVE A VOICE, ONE MORE VOICE
WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY EXPRESS
THEIR CONCERNS.
THE WHOLE IDEA OF THIS IS
PARENTAL EMPOWERMENT.
IF SCHOOL BOARDS ARE IGNORING
THE PARENTS, WE WILL TRY TO GIVE
THEM AS MANY AVENUES WHATSOEVER.
THIS IS NO DIFFERENT THAN WHEN
SCHOOL BOARDS ACCEPT EMAIL
SOLICITATION OF WHAT IS GOING ON
FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
WE ARE TO SAME LISTEN, WE JUST
WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
IF YOU ARE CONCERNED, JUST LET
US KNOW.
THIS IS ABOUT PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT AND PARENTAL
EMPOWERMENT.
>> Sean: WE APPRECIATE YOU.
WHEN WE COME BACK, PROVE THE
LEFT IS MORE CONCERNED WITH
UKRAINE'S BORDER THAN OUR OWN.
PLUS, EXCLUSIVE REPORTING FROM
SARA CARTER AND JULIO ROSAS
EXPOSING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND WHAT THEY